hey how's it going my name is Pippa
today we're doing something different we
always do something different we're
gonna play The Hunger Games simulator
I've spent probably two hours setting
this [ __ ] [ __ ] up I don't care if
this video [ __ ] sucks I'm gonna get
David the value out of this piece of
[ __ ] here we go oh my god I can't
believe it
so we have PewDiePie in district 1 with
med ship hi oh no only one can make it
out alive district 2 America player vs.
took 50 K naught versus I don't know
what they're the same team district 3
cinnamon toast Ken in the super
maryfayce district 4 cry and lord gaben
district 5 anthony smash ian smash
district 6 edgar Maya okay after this
point I'm like I'll [ __ ] it I'll add so
flattering um
they needed so many goddamn people I
don't know alright we have seen a nurse
2 in Tobuscus Taylor Swift that was out
of ideas alright and foxy Skye does mine
what is it mind what stop doing my stop
dantdm Freddy fazbear's Slenderman tax
or Nova spoon and those people you don't
know who they are
proceed okay so now it starts The Hunger
Games have started
the horn sound okay as such ask the
tribute stand on their podiums their
horn sounds I don't care
Freddy runs away from the cornucopia Fox
runs away from the cornucopia what a
bunch of [ __ ] am i right
Nova grabs a sword biodag runs away from
the cornucopia Mary and Markham ooh
fight for a bag market gives up and
retreats
so I guess married really wanted that
bag huh Felix runs away dammit mindset
grabs a shield leaning on the corner why
would you just grab a shield Marzia who
got Ian Smosh Dan and Toby Turner share
everything they gather before right Wow
our packs starting already and my dog is
involved what the [ __ ] Gabe runs away
Edgar runs away ken snatches a bottle of
alcohol and a rag this is the most
realistic thing I've seen in my life
well runs away Adam runs away
skydoesminecraft stays Taylor Swift
grabs a backpack not realizing it's
empty Oh Taylor pointlessblog runs away
Anthony smudge clutches the first aid in
most
they all run away okay proceed level two
hygge and fox split up to search for
resources spoon injured himself
dammit spoon don't do that oh my god ken
sets off an explosive killing zoella
Mary and Taylor Swift what the [ __ ] did
you do ken with the alcohol and the rug
you idiot
and why is Edgar practicing archery so
can literally just kill all the females
in this competition you've misogynist
Pig Akane three cannons shot can be
heard from a distance
zoella taylor swift do not look very
happy
proceed jack is unable to start a fire
and sleeps without one Felix
tends to fox moons now why would I do
that
spoon Christ asleep poor spoon ken
destroyed Gabe's supplies while he's
asleep
god dammit Kenny you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
everyone up man oh my god
Toby Turner attacks deck septic guy but
seananners protects her killing Toby
Turner Toby
No
spoon attempts to climb a tree but falls
to his death Anthony from Smosh begs
gaben to kill him he refuses keeping
Anthony Smosh alive but what the [ __ ]
how did that happen and Garen can sleep
in shifts
and no those sons of [ __ ] were
working together
pointless vlog convinces Nova to snuggle
with him well well played points us blog
well played now for [ __ ] sake ken
receives an explosive arrow and your
shoots an arrow it who gets what that's
your sister Ian Smosh picks flowers okay
Edgar receives an explosive arrow cat
[ __ ] damn it same one is king god
I know those sounds of big kiss I'm
rocking together Slenderman and Anthony
from Smosh hold hands the [ __ ] is this
Ken scares markimoo ah Dan what did you
do why would you scary markimoo can
someone [ __ ] die already
Nova sets an explosive arrow off killing
crying Jack Nova no what the [ __ ] is
this
Felix falls into a pit and dies you
can't just [ __ ] kill me
with a pig and was this Ken quietly hums
I [ __ ] know at Fox and Ken and
pointlessblog get into a fight
Fox triumphantly kills them both
so goodbye Ken okay good Ken's dead
Anthony steps on a landmine he's fine
Edgar begs for Marzia to kill him she
refuses keeping Edgar alive you gotta
kill me matzah I don't want to live in
this shitty Hunger Games know what kills
Dan for supplies what the [ __ ] you can't
just randomly kill my dog Edgar falls
into frozen lake and drowns Oh who got a
nova fight Gabe and Ian Smosh gaben Ian
smart survive damn it
okay rest in peace my two dogs - lets
Slendy on fire with a mallet oh [ __ ]
yeah go mites yeah I'm rooting for my
set right now
Ian Smosh actually accidentally
detonates a landmine while I was trying
to arm it yeah oh my god
marceia bashes Adams head against a rock
several times
Jesus Christ my gesture winner from
district 1 my district
oh my god well that turned out great
proceed to see the placements ah what
did I get which plays [ __ ] 16 Jesus
cry well I'm proud of you might say a
district one yeah that was fun yeah I
don't know if it's worth two hours
setting up the [ __ ] pictures but I'll
leave a link to their website if you
want to try it out yourself
well yeah I hope you guys enjoyed this
video click here for more leave a like
if you enjoyed watching and leave a
comment about much smashing someone's
head on a rock and I will see you in the
next one
stay awesome bros [ __ ] reddit ate me
[ __ ] you ready it clearly says don't eat
me after me now